hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich möchte heute etwas
leckeres backen und zwar gibt's ein
elefant brett auf deutsch ist ein
elefanten oder brot hat sich jetzt nicht
so gut an es geschafft kein elefant mit
drin
das ist einfach so ein hefeteig der wird
später mit butter und mit zimt zucker
also bestrichen und bestreut und wird
dann in kleine quadrate geschnitten und
dann in form geschichte und so wird
gebacken und es ist dann später
praktisch wie so eine art kuchen als
markant sich dann jemand diese einzelnen
blätter abzupfen und daneben auf essen
und ich glaube allein wegen der optik
ist es so und das machen wir jetzt heute
das ist ein ganz normaler standard
hefeteig die süße variante und ich zeige
euch kurz die zutaten
ich hab hier 500 gramm weizenmehl 200
milliliter milch 180 gramm zucker eine
würfel hefe ein teelöffel salz zu 2 3
esslöffel warmes wasser und 80 gramm
butter und ich hab das jetzt ein
bisschen schlecht vorbereitet denn ich
hatte keine frische hefe da und habe
deswegen meine hilfe aus dem gefrierfach
rausgenommen
das ist aber gar nicht schlimm ich habe
da immer so viel fünf würfel hefe drin
weil die kann man ganz einfach
einfrieren und später bei bedarf wieder
auftauen und entweder schaut dass ihr
dann im kühlschrank auffällig softe
variante zum beispiel den abend vorher
morgens oder ihr nehmt einfach mittel
warmes wasser und das tue ich jetzt
darin kurz auf und löst einfach direkt
die hefe darauf und es geht besser wenn
ein bisschen zucker nimmt das dauert
jetzt ein paar minuten aber das haben
wir gleich
stattdessen hat man es natürlich auch
trockenhefe nehmen können einfach zwei
päckchen aber die habe ich so gut wie
nie da weil ich irgendwie nie benutzt
aber es geht gleich
jetzt könnte das entweder weiter sondern
löffel einfach auftauen oder ich gebe es
jetzt halt kurz in einer küchenmaschine
denn die hat jetzt die wärme funktion
einfach rein mit der flüssigkeit will
muss halt zu warm machen
er soll damit die hilfe jetzt nicht
kaputt geht deswegen stelle ich das
jetzt hier einfach auf etwa 30 32 grad
und lassen es hier eben auftauchen
und wenn sich die hefe dann aufgelöst
hat gebe ich einfach die restlichen
zutaten dazu also noch den restlichen
zucker dass die mails die ich übrigens
auch zimmer warm also es ist nicht kalt
dann einen teil des mehls den rest geht
noch zum schluss mit dazu und das salz
und es lasse jetzt erstmal bisschen
verkneten gibt da noch die luft rein
jetzt gebe ich einfach noch bisher mail
dazu kann sein dass wir nicht das
komplette milch braucht aber auch dass
er einfach viel mehr als 500 gramm
braucht einfach so dass es ein schöner
weißer aber nicht zu fester teig wird
bringen sind einfach immer wieder
kontrollieren
und wenn ihr das dann habt laster den
teig so etwa fünf bis sieben minuten
kneten dann schon immer schön weiß und
klickt auf jeden fall bleiben
so sieht der teig jetzt aus wenn er
fertig ist und ihr merkt auch dass ein
hefeteig fertig bin dass ich vom
schlüssel rand löst und einfach nicht
mehr geht also ihr seht auch der klebt
ist auch nicht an den händen
jetzt kann ich ihnen hier raus nehmen
hätte was drin ist aber normal weil er
meine schüsse jetzt unten warm ist jetzt
nehme ich mir denn raus und form dem
kurz zu einer kugel zusammen
man sieht auch wenn man denn jetzt so
bewegt dann klebt er eben nicht an der
arbeitsfläche jetzt die kugel formen und
ich gehe das jetzt zurück in die
schüssel mit mir und lass den teig jetzt
so etwa eine halbe stunde auf gehen bis
stunde je nachdem wie bei euch die
temperatur eben ist und dann so schön
aufgegangen da kann man gleich weiter
derzeit tritt mich einfach noch ein
bisschen steht mein tag ist jetzt
aufgegangen und ich habe hier jetzt
schon meine backformen gerichtet und
zwar nämlich einfach so eine eckige
steinbach form könnte auch eine
auflaufform nehmen oder zb eine
springform egal was ihr habt jetzt nehme
ich meine arbeit nicht ganz leichten und
gebt den teig raus
kabinett extrem aufgehen lassen das
machen wir gleich wenn das dann alles in
der form treu steckt und jetzt muss ich
den bisschen eckig aus rollen könnte
jetzt entweder mit den fingern machen
oder machen im ausland stärken und das
mache ich jetzt
und jetzt habe ich hier einfach zimmer
warme butter und die streiche stolz
drauf also dies schön weich gut bis alt
sein dürfen
und jetzt habe ich hier noch etwas
zucker und bisschen zimt ich kann nicht
als keine genauen mengenangaben nehmen
ernennen weil es kommt darauf an wie co
sieht es aus gold und je nachdem wie süß
ihr das haben wollt ich habe glaube ich
so ungefähr 50 gramm zucker und gibt da
jetzt noch sind mit rein und das ist
auch nach eigenem belieben liebe zum
tier dann nehmt dann vermischtes ich mag
es eher zehn sieger
diesen zimt zucker nehme ich jetzt und
streut es sorgfältig drüber
und jetzt kann man im prinzip auch zum
beispiel noch gehackte nüsse oder
mandeln nehmen und die noch mit rein
streuen
also was eben wollt oder zum beispiel in
paris dienen die aber vorher in
apfelsaft oder rom einlegen damit sie
dann nicht verbrennen
aber ich weiß es ist einfach so kur ist
so ähnlich wie meine zimtschnecken durch
eben eine andere form also im prinzip
wenn ich sowas mit hefeteig mache und
den ausrollung bestreichen entweder
wissen news corp oder no stock oder
irgendwas einfach die form ist immer
anders und schmeckte habe bisschen
anders jedes mal so so viel zucker
dürfte reichen und nehme ich mir einfach
ein teig rädchen und schneit es in
quadrate wenn ich das eher zur lang
lassen würde könnte es auch wieso eine
ziehharmonika falten
dann wäre es so ähnlich von der form wie
man falten brot was ich im sommer immer
gern macht zum grill die herzhafte
variante
jetzt geht es ganz einfach ich lege mir
die jetzt so wissen übereinander und las
aber also nicht so komplett direkt
übereinander so ganz genau sondern ein
bisschen überlappend wiesn vertreten
ich habe übrigens immer mehrere kleine
häufchen gemacht denn wenn ihr das zu
hoch macht dann fällt das um
ich habe hier übrigens meine form
ausgetauscht also statt der großen form
nehme ich jetzt ne kleine weil ich
möchte dass das gewächs später in die
höhe geht und nicht in die breite
man könnte aber auch stattdessen zum
beispiel einfach eine kastenform
benutzen also das geht auch das hier
fertig jetzt mit back trinken damit
nicht sie lebt
und da sich die jetzt rein und zwar
nicht so sondern
das mache ich jetzt hier einfach so ein
bisschen versetzt dann kann das noch
darüber wandern und es kann darüber
wandern beim auf gehen einfach noch so
ein bisschen platz
und so werde ich das jetzt noch mal mit
etwas folie abdecken und nochmal
aufgehen lassen
so etwa 20 bis 30 minuten bis es so ein
bisschen aufgeht und dann packen wir das
gleich wo sind jetzt schon lecker aus
oder ich finde schon mein froh dass
jetzt aufgegangen und ich muss jetzt
natürlich vor dem backen die folie
entfernen
so sieht es jetzt aus und jetzt werde
ich im vorgeheizten backofen bei ober
und unterhitze ungefähr 170 180 grad für
ungefähr 30 bis 35 minuten backen
es wird im ofen jetzt auch noch mal ein
bisschen aufgehen und wenn so eine
schöne goldbraune farbe hat nämlich raus
und zeigt euch gleich das endergebnis
so sieht mein brot jetzt nach dem backen
aus ist immer komisch brot sagt man
eigentlich etwas süßes brot und ich
finde es so üblich holt es jetzt gar
nicht aus der form heraus bei mir dürfte
es 35 oder 40 minuten backen denn ihr
müsst aufpassen dass es in der mitte
eben nicht ruhig und weil ich jetzt die
schöne optik letzte stören will euch
aber trotzdem zeigen will wie das nimmt
zupfen lädt orange trägt es hier einfach
man kann hier schon sehen die blättern
ja wirklich schön voneinander ab und
wenn man das jetzt vor herausholten auf
dem teller gibt da kann sich das einfach
jedes unternehmen und wir denken ganz
gut dazu passen würden auch äpfel im
teig also wenn man den würfel schneiden
und einfach mit rein legt oder wie schon
gesagt apropos rosinen oder ja ganz
viele andere sachen also richter total
gut nach zimt
schmeckt genauso gut vor allem ist oben
sehr knusprig und unten eben sehr weich
und wenn er das rezept nach machen
wollte und her zwischen vollem mund und
probierte morath immer welches rezept
nachkochen machen wollt könnt ihr
nachlesen auf - blog.de und ich werde
das jetzt noch mal schön dekorieren und
für euch anrichten für facebook und
instagram und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal
die schmecken wie dies nun also stimmt
es gibt noch ein glas milch dazu
foto danach kriegt